today the paper I'm going to discuss
this frangipani this is a fairly old
distributed file system paper the reason
why were reading it though is because it
has a lot of interesting and good design
having to do with cache coherence and
distributed transactions and distributed
crash recovery as well as the
interactions between them so those are
those are the really the ideas behind
this that we're gonna try to tease out
so these are it's really a lot of our
caching coherence is really the idea of
if I have something cached that
nevertheless if you modify it despite me
having a cache you know something will
happen so I can see your your
modifications and we also have
distributed its actions which are needed
internally to file systems to be able to
make complex updates to the file system
data structures and because the file
system is essentially split up among a
bunch of servers it's critical to be
able to recover from crashes and those
servers the overall design a friend
pammi it's a network file system it's
intended to look to existing
applications this is intended to work
with existing applications like UNIX
programs ordinary UNIX programs we're
running on people's workstations much
like Athena's AFS lets you get at your
Athena home directory and various
project directories from any Athena
workstation so the kind of overall
picture is that you have a bunch of
users each user in the papers world is
sitting in front of a workstation which
is you know real not a laptop in those
days but sort of computer with a
keyboard and display in a mouse and
Windows system at all so each one is
sitting
front of a computer workstation I'm
gonna call the workstations you know
workstation one more station to each
workstation runs an instance of the
frangipani server I meant so a huge
amount of the you know almost all of the
stuff that happens in this paper goes on
in the frangipani software in each
workstation so maybe they're sitting in
front of a workstation and they might be
running ordinary programs like a text
editor that's reading and writing files
and maybe when they finished editing a
source file they run it through the
compiler that the Reiser source file
when these ordinary programs make file
system calls inside the kernel there's a
frangipani module that implements the
file system inside of all of these
workstations each other on copy and then
the real storage of the file system data
structures things like certainly file
contents but also I nodes and
directories and alissa file and each
directory and the information about what
I knows and what blocks are free all
that's stored in a shared virtual disk
surface called petal it's on a separate
set of machines that are you know
probably server machines and a machine
room rather than workstations on
people's desks pedal among many other
things replicates data so you can sort
of think of pedal servers is coming in
pairs and one crashes we can still get
at our data and so when frangipani
needs to read or write a you know read a
directory or something it sends a remote
procedure call off to the correct pedal
server to say well here's the block that
I need you know please read it for me
please return that block and for the
most part petal is acting like a disk
drive you can think of it as a kind of
shared as a shared disk drive that all
these frangipane knees talk to and it's
called a virtual disk
from our point of view for most of this
discussion we're just going to imagine
pedal is just being a disk ride that's
used over the network by all these
friends of Handy's and so it has you
read and write it by giving it a block
number or an address on the disk and
seem like I'd like to read that block
just like an ordinary hard drive okay so
the intended use for this file so the
use that the authors intended is
actually reasonably important driver in
the design what they wanted was to
support their own activities and what
they were were were members of a
research lab of maybe say 50 people in
this research lab and they were used to
shared infrastructure things like time
sharing machines or workstations using
previous network file systems to share
files among cooperating groups of
researchers so they both wanted they
they wanted a file system that they
could use to store their own home
directories in as well as storing shared
project files and so that meant that if
I edit a file I'd really like the other
people my work and the other people I
work with to be able to read the file I
just edited so we want that kind of
sharing and in addition it's great if I
can sit down at any workstation my
workstation your workstation a public
workstation in the library and still get
at all of the files of all my home
directory everything I need in my
environment so they're really interested
in a shared file system for human users
in a relatively small organization small
enough that everybody was trusted all
the people all the computers so really
the design has essentially nothing to
say about security and indeed arguably
would not work in an environment like
Athena where you can't really trust the
users or the workstations so it's really
very much designed for their their
environment now as far as performance
their environment was also important you
know it turns out that the way most
people use computers are leased
workstations they sit in front of is
that they mostly read and write their
own files and they may read some shared
files you know programs or some project
files or something but most of the time
I'm reading and writing my files and
you're reading and writing your files on
your workstation and you know it's
really the exception that we're actively
sharing files so it makes a huge amount
of sense to be able to one way or
another even though officially the real
copies of files are stored in this
shared disk it's fantastic if we can
have some kind of caching so that after
I log in and I use my files for a while
they're locally cached here so they can
be gotten gotten that and you know
microseconds instead of milliseconds if
we have to fetch them from the file
servers ok so French Pyrenees supported
this this kind of caching furthermore it
supported right-back caching not only
caching in each in each workstation and
each frangipani server we also have
right back caching which means that if I
want to modify something if I modify a
file or even create a file in a
directory or delete a file or basically
do any other operation as long as nobody
else no other workstation needs to see
it
frangipani acts with a write back cache
and that means that my writes stay only
local in the cache if I create a file at
least initially the information about
the newly created file said a newly
allocated inode with initialized
contents and you know a new entry added
to a new name attitudes to my home
directory all those modifications
initially are just done in the cache and
therefore things like creating a file
can be done extremely rapidly they just
require modifying local memory in this
machine's disk cache and they're not
written back in general to peddle until
later so at least initially we can do
all kinds of modifications to the file
system at least to my own directories my
own files completely locally and that's
enormous ly helpful for performance it's
like a you know factor of a thousand
difference being able to modify
something in local memory versus having
to send a remote procedure calls to send
server now one serious consequence of
that it's extremely determinative of the
architecture here is that that meant
that the logic of the file system has to
be in each workstation in order for my
workstation to be able to implement
things like create a file just operating
out of its local cache it means all the
logic all the intelligence for the file
system has to be sitting here in my
workstation and in their design
basically to a first approximation the
pedal shared storage system knows
absolutely nothing about file systems or
files or directories all that logic this
is a very in a sense very
straightforward simple system and all
the complexity is here in the frangipani
in each client so it's a very kind of
decentralized scheme and one of the
reasons is - because that's what you
really need or these that was a design
they could think of to allow them to do
modifications purely locally in each
workstation it does have the nice side
effect though that I'm since most of the
complexity and most of the CPU time
spent is spent here it means that as you
add workstations as you add users to the
system you automatically get more CPU
capacity to run those new users file
system operations because most file
system operations happen just locally in
the workstation that's most of the CPU
time is spent here so the system does
have a certain degree of natural scaling
scalability as you add workstations each
new workstation is a bit more load from
a new user but it's also a bit more
available CPU time to run that users
file system operations of course at some
point you're gonna run out of gas here
in the central storage system and you
know then you may need to add more
storage servers to all right
so okay so we have the system that does
serious caching here and furthermore
does the modifications in the cache that
actually these immediately to some
serious challenges in the design and the
design is mostly about solving the
challenges I'm about to lay out these
are largely count challenges of that's
come from caching and this sort of
decentralized architecture where most of
the intelligence is sitting in the
clients so the first challenge is that
suppose workstation one creates a file
in you know maybe a file say /a a new
file /a and initially it just creates
this in its local cache so that you know
first it may need to fetch the current
contents of the slash directory from
petal nom but then when it creates a
file just modifies its cached copy and
doesn't immediately send it back to
peddle then there's an immediate problem
here suppose the user on workstation 2
tries to get a directory listing of the
directory slash right we'd really like
to be able to this user see the newly
created file right and that's what users
are gonna expect and users will be very
confused if you know person down the
hall from me created a file and said oh
you know I put all this interesting
information in this new file /a why
don't you go read it and then I try to
read it and it's totally not there so we
absolutely want very strong consistency
if the person down the hall says they've
done something in the file system I
should be able to see it and if I edit a
file on one work station and then maybe
compile it on a computer on another
computer I want the compiler to see the
modifications I just made to my file
which means that the file system has to
do something to ensure that readers see
even the most recent rights so we've
been talking about this as we've been
calling this you know strong strong
consistency and linearize ability before
and that's basically what we want in the
context of caches though like the issue
here is not really about the storage
server necessarily it's about the fact
that there was a modification here that
needs to be seen somewhere else and now
for historical reasons that's usually
called cache coherence that is the
property of a caching system that even
if I have an old version of something
cached if someone else modifies it in
their cache then my cache will
automatically reflect their
modifications so we want this cache
coherence property another issue you
have is that the you know everything all
the files and directories are shared we
could easily have a situation where two
different workstations are modifying the
same directory at the same time so
suppose again maybe the user one on
their workstation wants to create a file
/a which is a new file in the directory
slash in the new in the root directory
and at the same time user two wants to
create a new file called slash B so at
some level you know they're creating
different files alright a and B but they
both need to modify the root directory
to add a new name to the root directory
and so the question is even if they do
this simultaneously you know to file
creations of differently named files but
in the same directory from different
workstations will the system be able to
sort out these concurrent modifications
to the same directory and arrive at some
sensible result and of course the
sensible result we want is that both a
and B end up existing we don't want to
end up with some you know situation in
which only one of them ends up existing
because the second modification
overwrote and sort of superseded the
first modification
and so this is again it goes by a lot of
different names but we'll call it a de
Missa T we want operations such as
create a file to lead a file to act as
if they just are instantaneous
instantaneous and time and don't ever
therefore don't ever interfere with
operations that occur at similar times
by other workstations
well things to happen just at a point in
time and not be spread over even if
they're complex operations and involve
touching a lot of state we want them to
appear as if they occur instantaneously
at a final problem we have is suppose
you know my workstation is modified a
lot of stuff and maybe it's
modifications are or many of its
modifications are done only in the local
cache because of this right back caching
if my were station crashes after having
modified some stuff in its local cache
and maybe reflected some but not all
those modifications back to storage
pedal other workstations are still
executing and they still need to be able
to make sense of the file system so the
fact that my workstation crashed while I
was in the middle of something had
better not wreck the entire file system
for everybody else or even any part of
it so that means what we need is crash
recovery of individual servers we won't
be able to have my workstation crash
without disturbing the activity of
anybody else using the same shared
system even if they look at my directory
in my files they should see something
sensible maybe it won't include the very
last things I did but they should see a
consistent file system and not a rekt
file system data structure so we want
crash recovery
as always with distributed systems
that's made more complex because we can
easily have a situation where only one
of the servers crashes but the others
are running and again for all of these
things for all three of these challenges
they're really challenged we're in this
discussion their challenges about how
frangipani works and how these
frangipani
software inside the workstations work
and so when I talk about a crash I'm
talking about a crash of a workstation
and it's frangipani you know the pedal
virtual disk has many similar questions
associated with it but there are not
really the focus today it has a
completely separate set of R'lyeh fault
tolerance machinery built into pedal and
it's actually a lot like the chain
replication kind of systems we talked
about earlier ok so I'm going to talk
about each of these challenges in turn
the first challenge is cache coherence
and the game here is to get both the
benefits of both linearize ability that
is when I read when I look at anything
in the filesystem I always see fresh
data I always see the very latest data
so we got both linearize ability and
caching not caching that's good caching
as we can get for performance so somehow
we you know we need to get the benefits
of both of these and the kind of that
people implement cache coherence that is
using what are called cache coherence
protocols and it turns out these
protocols are used a lot in many
different situations not just
distributed file systems but also things
like the caches in multi-core the per
core caches in multi core processors
also use cache coherence protocols which
are going to be not unlike the protocols
I'm going to describe for frangipani all
right
so it turns out that frangipani x' cache
coherence is driven by its use of locks
and we'll see locks come up later in
both actually for both atomicity and
crash recovery but the particular use of
locks I'm going to talk about for now is
a use of blocks to drive cache coherence
to help workstations ensure that even
though they're caching data they're
caching the latest data so as well as
the frangipani servers and workstations
and pedal servers there's a third kind
of server in the frangipani system
there's lock servers and so we're I'm
just gonna pretend there's one lock
server although you could shard the
locks over multiple servers so here's a
lock server it's a separate you know
it's logically at least a separate
computer although I think they ran them
on the same hardware as the pedal
servers but it basically just has a
table of named locks and locks are named
we'll consider them to be named after a
named as after file names although in
fact they're named after I numbers so we
have for every file we have a lock
potentially and each lock is possibly
owned by some owner for this discussion
I'm just gonna assume I'm gonna describe
it as if the locks were exclusive locks
although in fact frangipani has a more
complicated scheme for locks that allow
either one writer or multiple readers so
for example maybe file X has recently
been used by workstation 1 and
workstation 1 has a lock on it and maybe
file Y is recently used by workstation 2
and workstation 2 has a lock on it and
the lock server will remember off or
each file
who has the lock if anyone maybe nobody
does on that file and then in each
workstation
each workstation keeps track of which
locks it holds and this is tightly tied
to it
I'm keeping track of cache data as well
so in each workstations frangipani
module there's also a lock table and
record what file the more session to
lock for what kind of lock it has and
the contents the cached contents of that
file so that might be a whole bunch of
data blocks or maybe directory contents
for example so there's a lot of content
here so Linda frangipani server decides
oh it needs to read it needs to use the
directory slash or look at the file a or
look at an inode it first gets asked the
lock server for a lock on whatever it's
about to use and then it asks petal to
get the data for whatever that file or
directory or whatever it is and it needs
to read and then the workstation
remembers oh ho you know I have a copy
of file X its content is whatever the
content of file X is cached and it turns
out that workstations can have a lock in
at least two different modes what the
workstation can be actively reading or
writing whatever that file or directory
is right now that it's in the middle of
a file creation operation or deletion or
rename or something so in that case I'll
say that the lock is held by the
workstation and is busy it could also be
after a workstation has done some
operation like create a file or maybe
read a file
you know then release the lock as soon
as it's done with that system call
whatever system call like rename or read
or write or create as soon as the system
calls over the workstation will give up
the lock at least internally it's not
actively using that file anymore but
it'll as far as the lock server is
concerned the workstation will hold the
lock but the workstation notes for it
its own use that it's not actively using
that lock anymore as well call that the
lock is still held by the workstation
I'm just but the work station isn't
really using it and that'll be important
in a moment okay so I think these two
are set up consistently if we assume
this is workstation one the lock server
knows Oh locks for x and y exists and
they're both held by workstation one
workstation one has equivalent
information in its table it knows it's
holding these two blocks and furthermore
it has the it's remembering the content
is cached for the filers of directories
that the two locks cover there's a
number of rules here that in that
frangipani follows that caused it to use
locks in a way that provide cache
coherence then sure nobody's ever
meaning using stale data from their
cache so so these are basically rules
that are using conjunction with the
locks and cache data so one the really
overriding invariant here is that no
workstation is allowed to cache data to
hold any cached data unless it also
holds the lock associated with that data
so basically it's no cache data without
a lock without the lock that protects
that data and operationally what this
means is a workstation before it uses
data it first acquires the lock on the
data from the lock server and after the
workstation has the lock only then does
the workstation read the data from petal
and put it and put it in its cache so so
the sequence is you can acquire a lock
and then read from petal
I'll tell you at the lock of course you
know you weren't passing the data you
want to catch the data you first got to
get the lock and only strictly
afterwards read from petal and if you
ever release a lock then the rule is
that before releasing a lock you first
have to write if you modified the lock
data in your cache before you release
the lock you have to write the data back
to modify data back to petal and then
only when petals as yes I got the data
only then you'll have to release the
lock that is gives a lock back to the
lock server so the sequence is always
first you write the cache dated a petal
storage system and then release the lock
and erase the entry whoops
erase the entry and the cat and the
cache data from your from that
workstations lock table what this
results in the the protocol between the
lock server and between the workstations
and the lock server consists of four
different kinds of messages this is the
coherence protocol these are just
network you can think of them as
essentially sort of one-way Network
messages there's a request message from
from workstations to the lock server
request message says oh hey lock server
I'd like to get this lock when the lock
server is willing to give you the lock
and of course if somebody else holds if
the lock server can't immediately give
you the lock but if when the lock
becomes free the lock server will
respond we have a grant message then the
lock server back to the workstation in
response to an earlier request well if
you request a lock for the lock server
and someone else holds the lock right
now that other workstation has to first
give up the lock we can't have two
people owning the same lock so how are
we going to get that works
the lock well what I said here is that
when a lock station is you know when
it's actually using the lock and
actively reading or writing something it
has the lock and it's marked it busy but
the workstations don't give up their
locks ordinarily when they're done using
them so if I if I create a file and then
create system call finishes I'll still
have that file that new file locked and
also own the lock for that my
workstation will still all in the lock
for that file it'll just be in state
idle instead of busy but as far as the
lock server is concerned
well my workstation still has the lock
and the reason for this the reason to be
lazy about handing locks back to the
lock server is that if I create a file
called Y on my workstation
I'm almost certainly going to be about
to use Y for other purposes like maybe
write some data to it or read from it or
something so it's extremely advantageous
for the workstation to sort of
accumulate locks for all of the recently
used files in the workstation and not
give them back unless it really has to
and so in the ordinary in the common
case in which I use a bunch of files in
my home directory and nobody else on any
other workstation ever looks at them my
workstation ends up accumulating dozens
or hundreds of locks in idle state for
my files but if somebody else does look
at one of my files they need to first
get the lock and I have to give up the
lock so the way that works is that if
the lock server receives a lock request
and it sees in the lock server table AHA
you know that lock is currently owned by
workstation 1 the lock server will send
a revoke message to whoever the
workstation that currently owns that
lock saying look you know somebody else
wants it please give up the lock when a
workstation receives a revoke request if
the lock is idle then if the cache data
is dirty the workstation will first
write the cat dirty data that modified
data from his cache back to peddle
because the rule says the rule that in
order to never cache data without a lock
says we got our right the modify dated
back to peddle before releasing so if
the locks idle would first write back
the data if it's modified back to peddle
and
then send a message back to the lock
server saying it's okay we give up this
lock so the response to revoke send to a
workstation is the worst station sends
it released of course if the worst
station gets a revoke while it's
actively using a lock while it's in the
middle of a delete or rename or
something that affects the locked file
the worst station will not give us a
lock until it's it's done using and
until it's finished that file system
operation whatever system call it was
that was using this file and then the
lock in the worst stations lock state
will transition to idle and then you'll
be able to pay attention to the revoke
request and after writing to peddle if
need be released the lock alright so
this is the is the coherence protocol
that fringe that well this is a
simplification of the coherence protocol
that frangipani uses as I mentioned
before what's missing from all this is
the fact that locks can be either
exclusive for writers or shared for
read-only access and just like petal is
a block server and doesn't understand
anything about file systems the lock
server also these IDs these are really
lock identifiers and the locks are
doesn't know anything about files or
directories or file system it just has
these it's just has this table with
opaque IDs and who owns you know that
name locks and who owns those locks and
it's frangipani that knows ah you know
the lock that I associate was he given a
file has such and such an identifier and
as it happens prin Japan uses unix-style
I numbers or the numbers associated with
files instead of names for locks so just
to make this coherence protocol concrete
and to illustrate again the relationship
between petal operations
and lock server operations let me just
run through what happens if one
workstation modifies some file system
data and then in another workstation
means to look at it so we have two
workstations the lock server so the way
the protocol plays out if workstation
one wants to read since a workstation
one wants to read and then modify files
e so before it can even read anything
about Z from peddle it must first
acquire the lock for Z so it sends an
acquire request to the lock server maybe
nobody holds the lock or lock servers
never heard anything about it
so the locks are makes a new entry for Z
and it stable returns our reply saying
yes
you own the grant for lock C and at this
point the workstation says it has the
lock on file Z isn't entitled to read
information about it from petal so at
this point we're gonna read Z from petal
and indeed workstation one can modify it
locally in their cache at some later
point maybe the human being and sitting
in front of workstation two wants to
also to read file Z while the
workstation two doesn't have the lock
for files the ISA the very first thing
it needs to do is send a message the
lock server saying oh yeah I'd like to
get the lock for file Z the lock server
knows it can't reply yes yet because
somebody else has the lock namely
workstation one my the lock server sends
in response a revoke
the workstation one workstation one not
allowed to give up the lock until it
writes any modified data back to the
pedal so it's now gonna write the model
anything modified content the actual
contents of the file with always
modified back to pedal only then is
workstation two allowed to send a
release back to the lock server the lock
server with must have kept a record in
some table saying well you know there's
somebody waiting for lock Z as soon as
its current holder releases that we need
to reply and so this receipt of this
release will cause the lock server to
update its tables and finally send the
grant back to or station two and at this
point now our station two can finally
read files even pedal this is how the
cache coherence protocol plays out to
ensure that everybody who does a read
doesn't read the data until whoever the
previous until anybody who might have
had the data modified privately in their
cache first writes the data back to
pedal all right so the locking machinery
forces reads to see the latest right so
what's going on there's a number of the
optimizations that are possible in these
kind of cache coherence protocols
I mean I've actually already described
one this idle state the fact that
workstations hold onto locks that
they're not using right now instead of
immediately releasing them that's
already an optimization to the simplest
protocol you can think of and the other
main optimization is that the frangipani
has is that it has a notion of shared
versus shared read locks versus
exclusive write locks so have lots and
lots of workstations need to be
the same file but nobody's writing it
they can all have a lock a read lock on
that file and if somebody does come
along and try to write this file that's
widely cached they first need to first
revoke everybody's read lock so that
everybody gives up their cached copy and
only then is a right or allowed to write
the file but it's okay now because
nobody has a cache copy anymore so
nobody could be reading stale data while
it's being written all right so that's a
cache coherence story driven by driven
by the locking protocol next up in our
list of yes yes that's a good question
in fact there's a risk here in the
scheme I described that if I modify a
file on my workstation and nobody else
reads it for nobody else reads it that
the only copy of the modified file maybe
have some precious information in it is
on in in the cache in RAM on my
workstation and my works they were to
crash then and you know we hadn't done
anything special then it would have
crashed with the only copy of the data
and the data would be lost so in order
to forestall this no matter what all
these workstations write back anything
that's in their cache any modified stuff
in their cache every 30 seconds so that
if my workstation crash is unexpectedly
I may lose the last 30 seconds at work
but no more there's actually just mimics
the way ordinary Linux or UNIX works
indeed all of this a lot of the story is
about in the context of a distributed
file system trying to mimic the
properties that ordinary unix-style
workstations have so that users won't be
surprised by frangipani it just sort of
works much the same way that they're
already used
all right so our next challenge is how
do you atomicity that is how to make it
so even though when I do a complex
operation like creating a file which
after all involves marking a new I
knowed as allocated initializing the
inode the I knows a little piece of data
that describes each file maybe
allocating space for the file adding a
new name in the directory for my new
file there's many steps so many things
that have to be updated we don't want
anybody to see any of the intermediate
steps we want people you know other
workstations to either see the file not
exist or completely exist but not
something in between one atomic
multi-step operations alright so in
order to implement this in order to make
multi-step operations like file create
or rename or delete atomic as far as
other workstations are concerned
frangipani has a implement the notion of
transactions that is as a complete sort
of database style transaction system
inside it again driven by the locks
furthermore it it's it's this is
actually distributed transaction system
and we'll see more we'll hear more about
distributed transaction systems later in
the course
there are like a very common requirement
and distributed systems the basic story
here is that frangipani makes it so that
other workstations can't see my
modifications until completely done by
an operation by first acquiring all the
locks on all the data that I'm going to
need to read or write during my
operation and not releasing any of those
locks until it's finished with the
complete operation and of course
following the coherence rule written all
of the modified data back to petal
so before I do an operation like
renaming like moving a file from one
directory to another which after all
modifies both directories and I don't
want anybody to see the file being in
either directory or something in the
middle of the operation in order to do
in order to do this French penny first
acquires require all the locks for the
operation then do everything like all
the updates right the frangipani so I
write to pedal and then release and of
course this is easy button and you know
since we already had the locking server
anyway in order to drive the cache
coherence protocol we buy just by you
know making sure we hold all the locks
for the entire duration of an operation
we get these indivisible atomic
transactions almost for free so an
interesting thing to know and that's
basically all there is to say about
making operations atomic and transit
Pandu's hold all the locks an
interesting thing about this use of
locks is that trends of pennies using
locks for - almost opposite purposes for
cache coherence frangipani uses the
locks to make sure that writes are
visible immediately to anybody who wants
to read them so this is all about using
locks essentially to kind of make sure
people can see writes this use the
blocks is all about making sure people
don't see the writes until I'm finished
with an operation because I hold all the
locks until all the rights have been
done so they're sort of playing an
interesting trick here by reusing the
locks they would have had to have anyway
for transactions in order to drive cache
coherence
all right so the next interesting thing
is crash recovery we need to cope with
the possibility the most interesting
possibility is that a workstation
crashes while holding locks and while in
the middle of some sort of complex set
of updates that is a reforestation
acquired a bunch of locks it's writing a
whole lot of data to maybe create or
delete files or something has possibly
written some of those modifications back
to pedal because maybe it was gonna soon
release locks or had been asked by the
lock server to release locks so it's
maybe done some of the rights back to
pedal for its complex operations but not
all of them and then crashes before
giving up the locks so that's the
interesting situation for crash recovery
so there's a number of things that that
don't work very well for workstation
crashes crashing we hope one thing that
doesn't work very well is to just
observe the workstations crashed and
just release all its locks because then
if it's done something like created a
new file and it's written the files
directory entry its name back to pedal
but it hasn't yet written the
initialized inode that describes the
file the inode may still be filled with
garbage or the previous file some
previous files information in petal and
yet we've already written the directory
entry so it's not okay to just release a
crashed file servers release of crash
were stations locks another thing that's
not okay is to not release the crashed
workstations locks you know that would
be correct because you know if it
crashed while in the middle of writing
out some of this modifications the fact
that it hadn't written out all of them
means a can't of release its locks
so simply not releasing its locks is
correct because it would hide the this
partial update from any readers and so
nobody would ever be confused by seeing
partially updated data structures in
petal on the other hand you know then
anybody you needed to use those files
would have to wait forever for the locks
if we simply didn't give them up so we
absolutely have to give up the locks in
order that other workstations can use
the system can use those same files and
directories but we have to do something
about the fact that the workstation
might have done some of the rights but
not all for its operations so frangipani
has like almost every other system that
needs to implement crashed recoverable
transactions users right ahead logging
this is something we've seen at least
one instance of the last lecture with
with aurora i was also using right ahead
logging so the idea is that if a
workstation needs to do a complex
operation that involves touching
updating many pieces of data in petal in
the file system the workstation well
first before it makes any rights to
petal append a la log entry to his log
in petal describing the full set of
operations it's about to do and only
when that log entry describing the full
set of operations is safely in petal
where now anybody else can see it only
then will the workstation start to send
the rights for the operation out to
petal I'm so we if it were station could
ever reveal even the one of its rights
for an operation the petal it must have
already put the log entry describing the
whole operation all of the updates must
already exist in petal so this is very
standard this is just a description of
right ahead logging
but there's a couple of odd aspects of
how frangipani implements right ahead
logging
the first one is that in most
transaction systems there's just one log
and all the transactions in the system
you know they're all sitting there in
one log in one place so there's a crash
and there's opera there's more than one
operation that affects the same piece of
data we have all of those operations for
that piece of data and everything else
right there in the single log sequence
and so we know for example which is the
most recent update to a given piece of
David but frangipani doesn't do that
this it has her work station logs as one
log per work station and there's
separate logs the other very interesting
thing about frangipane ease logging
system is that the LA workstation logs
are stored in petal and not on local
disk in almost every system that uses
logging the log is tightly associated
with whatever computer is running the
transactions that it's almost always
kept on a local disk but for extremely
good reasons
frangipani workstations
store their logs in petal in the shared
storage each workstation had its own
sort of semi-private log but it's stored
in petal storage where if the
workstation crashes its log can be
gotten that by other workstations so the
logs are in petal and this is this is
like separate logs for workstation
stored somewhere else in public sort of
shared storage so like a very
interesting and unusual arrangement all
right so we kind of need to know roughly
what's in the law what's in a log entry
and unfortunately the papers not super
explicit about the format of a log entry
but we can imagine that the well the
paper does say that each workstations
log sits in a known place a known range
of block numbers in petal and
furthermore that each workstation uses
its log space and petal on a kind of in
a circular way that it is all right log
entries along from the beginning and
when it hits the end the workstation
will go back and reuse its log space
back at the beginning of its log area
and of course that means that were
stations need to be able to you know
clean their logs so that sort of ensure
that a log entry isn't needed before
that space is reused and I'll talk about
that in a bit but each a log consists of
a sequence of log entries each log entry
has a log sequence number it's just an
increasing number each workstation
numbers it's log entries 1 2 3 4 5 and
the immediate reason for this may be the
only reason for this that the paper
mentions is that the the way that French
penny just detects the end of a work
stations log if the work station crashes
is by scanning for words in its log in
petal until it sees the increasing
sequence stop increasing and it knows
then that the log entry with the highest
log sequence number must be the very
last entry as it needs to be able to
detect the end of the log ok so we have
this log sequence number and then I
believe each log actually has an an
array
of descriptions of model aughh entry has
an array of the descriptions of the
modifications all the different
modifications that were involved in a
particular operation or an operation of
some a file system system call so each
entry in the array is going to have a
block number it's a block number in
petal there's a version number which
we'll get to in a bit and then there's
the data to be written and so there's a
bunch of these required to describe
operations that might touch more than
one piece of data in the file system one
thing to notice is that the log only
contains information about changes to
metadata that is to directories and
inodes and allocation bitmaps in the
file system the log doesn't actually
contain the data that is written to the
contents of files it doesn't contain the
user's data it just contains information
enough information to make the file
systems structures recoverable after a
crash so for example if I create a file
called F in a directory that's gonna
result in a new log entry that has two
little descriptions of modifications in
it one a description of how to
initialize the new files inode and in
another description of a new name to be
placed in the new files directory
alright so one thing I didn't mention so
of course the log is really a sequence
of these log entries
initially in order to be able to do
modifications as fast as possible
initially a friend Japanese workstations
log is only stored inside the
workstations own memory and won't be
written back to peddle until it has to
be and that's so that you know writing
anything including log entries to peddle
you know it takes a long time so we want
to avoid even writing log entries back
to peddle as well as writing dirty data
or modified blocks back to peddle we'd
like to avoid doing that as long as
possible so the real full story for what
happens when a workstation gets a revoke
message from the lock server seeing that
it has to give up a certain lock so on
right now this is the same you know this
is though compared sporto's
protocols revoke message if the
workstation gets a revoke message the
series of steps it must take is first
it's great that's the right any parts of
its log that are only in memory and
haven't yet been written to peddle it's
got to make sure as log is complete and
pedal as the first step so it writes
it's long and only then does it write
any updated blocks that are covered by
the lock that's being revoked so write
modified blocks
just for that provoked to lock and then
send a release message and the reason
for this sequencing and for this strict
ban is that these modifications if we
write them to peddle you know their
modifications to the data structure the
file system data structure and if we
were to crash midway through baby news
box just as usual we want to make sure
that some other workstation somebody
else there's enough information to be
able to complete the set of
modifications that the were station is
made even though the workstation has
crashed and maybe didn't finish doing
these rights and writing the log first
it's gonna be what allows us to
accomplish it these these log records
are a complete description of what these
modifications are going to be so first
we you know first we write though the
complete log to petal and then we
workstation can start writing its
modified blocks you know maybe it
crashes maybe doesn't hopefully not and
if it finishes writing as modified
blocks then it could send the release
back to the lock server so you know if
my workstation has modified a bunch of
files and then some other workstation
wants to read one of those files this is
the sequence that happens lock so ever
asked me for my locks right back my
workstation right back said log then
right back
writes the dirty modified blocks to
peddle and only then releases and then
the other workstation can acquire the
lock and read these blocks so that's
sort of the non crash you know if a
crash doesn't happen that is the
sequence of course it's only interesting
if a crash happens yes
[Music]
okay so for the log you're absolutely
right it writes the entire log and yeah
so so if if we get a revoke for a
particular file the workstation will
write its entire log and then only it's
only because it's only giving up the
lock for Z it it only needs to write
back data that's covered by Z so I have
to write the whole log just the data
that's covered by the lock that we
needed to give up and then we can
release that lock so yeah you know maybe
this writing the whole log might be
overkill like you if it turned out you
know so here's an optimization that you
might or might not care about if the
last modification for profile Z for the
lock were giving up is this one but
subsequent entries in my log didn't
modify that file then I could just write
just this prefix of my in-memory log
back to petal and you know be lazy about
writing the rest and that might see me
sometime
I might have to write the log back it's
actually not clear I would save us a lot
of time we have to write the log back at
some point anyway and yeah I think petal
just writes the whole thing okay okay so
now we can talk about what happens when
a workstation crashes while holding
locks right it's you know needs to
modify something rename a file create a
file whatever it's acquired all the
locks it needs it's modified some stuff
in its own cache to reflect these
operations maybe written some stuff back
to petal and then crashed men possibly
midway through writing so there's a
number of points at which it could crash
right because this is always the
sequence it always just always before
writing modified blocks from the cache
back
the frangipani will always have written
it's logged pedal first that means that
if a crash happens it's either while the
worst station is writing us log back to
pedal but before it's written any
modified file or directory' blocks back
or it crashes while it's writing these
modified block back but therefore
definitely after it's written in its
entire log and so that's a very
important you know but or maybe the
crash happened after it's completely
finished all of this so you know there's
only because of the sequencing there's
only a limited number of kind of
scenarios we made me worried about for
the crash okay so the workstations
crashed its crashed you know for like to
be exciting let's crash while Holdings
locks the first thing that happens the
lock server sends it a revoke request
and the lock server gets no response all
right that's what starts to trigger
anything where did nobody ever asked for
the lock
basically nobody's ever going to notice
that the workstation crashed so let's
assume somebody else wanted one of the
locks that the workstation had while it
was crashed and the lock service ended
revoke and it will never get a release
back from the workstation after a
certain amount of time has passed and it
turns out frangipani locks use leases
for a number of reasons so you know
after the least time has expired the
lock server will decide that the
workstation must have crashed and it
will initiate recovery and what that
really means is telling a different
workstation the lock server will tell
some other live workstation look
workstation one seems to have crashed
please go read it's log and replay all
of its recent operations to make sure
they're complete and tell me when you're
done and only then the lock servers
going to release the locks so okay so
and and this is the point at which it
was critical that the logs are in pedal
because some other workstation is going
to inspect the crash workstations log in
pedal
all right so what are the possibilities
one is that the worst that you can crash
before it ever wrote anything back and
so that means this other work station
doing recovery will look at the crash
workstation this log see that maybe
there's nothing in it at all and do
nothing and then release the locks the
workstation held now the worst that you
may have modified all kinds of things in
its cache but if it didn't write
anything to his log area then it
couldn't possibly have written any of
the blocks that have modified during
these operations right and so well we
will have lost the last few operations
that the workstation did the file system
is going to be consistent with the point
in time before that crashed workstation
started to modify anything because
apparently the workstation never even
got to the point where it was writing
log entries the next possibilities of
the workstation wrote some log entries
the log area and in that case the
recovering workstation will scan forward
from the beginning of log until it's
stopped seeing the log sequence numbers
increasing that's the point of where's
the log must Anton and the recovering
workstation we'll look at each of these
descriptions of a change and basically
play that change back into petal I'll
say oh you know there's certain block
number and petal needs to have some
certain data written to it which is just
the same modification that the crashed
workstation did in its own local cache
so the recovering workstation we'll just
consider each of these and replay each
of the crashed workstations log entries
back into petal and when it's done that
all the way to the end of a crashed
workstations log as it exists in petal
it'll tell the lock server and the lock
server will release the crashed
workstations locks and that will bring
the pedal up to date with some prefix of
the operations the crash workstation had
done before crashing maybe not all of
them because maybe it didn't write out
all of its log but the recovery were
season
won't replay anything in a log entry
unless it has the complete log entry in
petal and so you know implicitly that
means there's gonna be some sort of
checksum arrangement or something so the
recovery work station will know aha this
log entry is complete and not like
partially written that's quite important
because the whole point of this is to
make sure that only complete operations
are visible and petal and never never
never a partial operation so it's also
important that all the rights for a
given operation or a group together in
the log so that on recovery the recovery
workstation can do all of the rights for
an operation or none of them never half
of them ok so that's what happens if the
crash happens while the log is being
written back to petal a another
interesting possibility is that the
crash workstation crashed after writing
its log and also after writing some of
the blocks back itself and then crashed
and then skimming over some extremely
important details which I'll get to in a
moment then what will happen is again
the recovery workstation of course the
recovery where station doesn't know
really the point at which the
workstation crashed all it sees is oh
here's some log entries and again the
recovery workstation will replay the log
in the same way and more or less what's
going on is that yeah even if the
modifications were already done in petal
we're replaying the same modifications
here the recovery where students were
playing the same modifications it just
writes the same data the same place
again and presumably not really changing
the value for the writes that had
already been completed but if the crash
workstation hadn't done some of its
rights then some of these rights were
not sure which will actually change the
data to complete the operations all
right
that's not actually as it turns out the
full story and today's question sets up
a particular scenario for which a little
bit of added complexity is necessary in
particular the possibility that the
crashed workstation had actually gotten
through this entire sequence before
crashing and in fact released some of
its locks or so that it wasn't the last
person the last workstation to modify a
particular piece of data so an example
of this is what happens if we have some
workstation and it executes say a delete
file it deletes a file say a file F and
directory D and then there's some other
workstation which after this delete
creates a new file with the same name
but of course it's a different file now
so workstation 1 I'm sorry
workstation two later create create same
file same file name and then after that
workstation 1 crashes so we're going to
need you to do recovery on workstation
ones log and so at this point in time
you know maybe there's a third
workstation doing the recovery
so now workstation 3 is doing a recover
on workstation ones log so the sequence
says workstation 1 deleted a file or
station 2 created a file or station 3
does recovery well you know could be
that this delete is still in workstation
ones log so workstation two may you know
or station 1 crash just going to go or
station 3 is going to look at its log
that's going to replay all
all the updates in workstation ones log
this delete may the updates for this
delete the entry for this delete may
still be in workstation ones log so
unless we do something clever
workstation 3 is going to delete this
file you know because this this
operation erased the relevant entry from
the directory
thus actually erasing deleting this file
that's it's a different file that
workstation 2 created afterwards so
that's completely wrong alright what we
want you know the how come we want is
you know horse station one deleted a
file that file should be deleted but a
new file that if her name should not be
deleted just because it was a crash in a
restart cuz this create happen after
delete all right so we cannot just
replay workstation ones log without
further thought because it may it may
essentially a log entry in workstations
one log may be out of date by the time
it's we played during recovery some
other workstation may have modified the
same data and some other way
subsequently so we can't blindly replay
the log entries and so this is this is
this is today's question and the way
frangipani solves this is by associating
version numbers with every piece of data
in the file system as stored in pedal
and also associating the same version
number with every update that's
described in the log so every log entry
when well first I don't have any that's
you know say in pedal I'll just say in
pedal every piece of metadata every
inode every every piece of data that's
like the contents of a directory for
example every block of data metadata in
stored and pedal has a version number
when a workstation needs to modify a
piece of metadata in pedal it first
reads that metadata from pedal into its
memory and then looks at the existing
version of
and then when it's creating the log file
describing its modification it puts the
existing version number plus one into
the log entry and then when it in if it
does get a chance to write the data back
it'll write the data back with the new
increased version number so if over
station hasn't crashed and it did or if
it did manage to write some data back
before it crashed then the version
number has stored in petal for the
effected metadata it will be at least as
high or higher than the version numbers
stored in the log entry there will be
higher some other workstations
subsequently modified so what will
actually happen here is that the what
workstation 3 we'll see is that the log
entry for workstations one delete
operation will have a particular version
number stored in the log entry that
associated with the modification to the
directory let's say and the log entry
will say well the version number for the
directory and the new version number
created by this log entry is version
number three in order for workstation
two to subsequently change the directory
that is to add a file app in fact before
it crashed the workstation one must have
given up the lock in the directory and
that's probably why the log entry even
exists in pedal so workstation 1 must
have given up the lock apparently
workstation two got the lock and read
the current metadata for the directory
saw that the version number was three
now and when workstation two writes this
data it will set the version number or
the directory in peddle to be 4 ok so
the that means the log entry for this
delete operation is going to have
version number 3 in it now when the
recovery software on worst agent 3
replays workstation ones log it looks at
the version numbers first so it'll look
at the version number the log entry
it'll read the block from
look at the version number in the block
and if the version number in the block
in pedal is greater than or equal to the
version number in the log entry the
recovery software will simply ignore
that update in the log entry and not do
it because clearly the block had already
been written back by the crash
workstation and then maybe subsequently
modified by other workstations so the
replay is actually selectively based on
this version number that replay it's a
recovery only writes only
replays are right in the log if that
right is actually newer right in the log
entry is newer than the data that's
already stored in peddle so one sort of
irritating question here maybe is that
workstation three is running this
recovery software while other
workstations are still reading and
writing in the file system actively and
have locks and knows what to peddle so
the replay it's gonna go on while we're
station to which that doesn't know
anything about the recovery still active
and indeed workstation two may have the
lock for this directory
while recoveries going on so recovery
may be scanning the log and you no need
to read or write this directories data
in pedal while workstation two still has
the lock on this data the question is
how you know how do we sort this out
like one possibility which actually
turns out not to work is for the
recovery software to first acquire the
lock on anything that it needs to look
at in petal before while it's replaying
the log and the the you know one good
reason why that doesn't work is that it
could be that we're running recovery
after a system-wide power failure for
example in which all knowledge of who
had what locks is lost and therefore we
cannot write the recovery software to
sort of participate in the locking
protocol because
you know all knowledge of what's locked
my slot not locked may have been lost in
the power failure
um but luckily it turns out that the
recovery software can just go ahead and
read or write blocks in pedal without
worrying about sorry read or write data
in pedal without worrying at all about
locks and the reason is that if the
recovery software you know the recovery
software wants to replay this log entry
and possibly modify the data associated
with this directory it just goes ahead
and reads whatever's there for the
directory out of pedal right now and
there's really only two cases either the
crash workstation one had given up its
lock or it hadn't if it hadn't given up
this lock then nobody else can have a
directory locked and so there's no
problem if it had given up its lock then
before I gave it up its lock it must
have written that it's data for the
directory back to pedal and that means
that the version number stored in pedal
must be at least as high as the version
number in the crashed workstations log
entry and therefore when recovery
software compares the log entry version
number with the version number of the
data and pedal it'll see that the log
entry version number is not higher and
therefore won't we play the log entry so
yeah the recovery software will have
read the block without holding the lock
but it's not going to modify it because
if the locked was released the version
number will be high enough to show that
the log entry had already been sort of
processing to pedal before the crashed
workstation crashed no so there's no
locking issue alright this is the I've
gone over that kind of main guts of what
pedal is up to Nam it's cache coherence
it's distributed transactions and it's
distributed crash recovery the other
things to think about are the the paper
talks a bit about performance it's
actually very hard after over 20 years
to interpret performance numbers because
they brand their performance numbers on
very different Hardware in a very
different environment from
you see today roughly speaking the
performance numbers they show or that as
you add more and more friendship and
work stations the system basically
doesn't get slower that is each new
workstation even if it's actively doing
file system operations doesn't slow down
the existing workstation so in that
sense the system you know at least for
the application state look at the system
was giving them reasonable scalability
they could add more workstations without
slowing existing users down looking
backwards
although frangipani is full of like very
interesting techniques that are worth
remembering it didn't have too much
influence in on how on the evolution of
storage systems part of the reason is
that the environment for which is aimed
that is small workgroups
people sitting in front of workstations
on their desks and sharing files that
environment well it still exists in some
places isn't really where the action is
in distributed storage the action the
real action is moved into sort of big
data center or big websites big data
computations and there you know in that
world first of all the file system
interface just isn't very useful
compared to databases like people really
like transactions in the big website
world but they need them for very small
items of data the kind of data that you
would store in a database rather than
the kind of data that would you would
naturally store in a file system so you
know some of this technology might sort
of you can see echoes of it in modern
systems but it usually takes the form of
some database the other big kind of
storage this out there is storing big
files as needed for big data
computations like MapReduce and indeed
GFS is a you know to some extent looks
like a file system and is the kind of
storage system you want for MapReduce
but for GFS and for big data
computations frangipane ease you know
focus on local caching and workstations
and very close attention to
cache coherence and locking it's just
not very useful you know for both the
data read and write
typically caching is not useful at all
right if you're reading through ten
terabytes of data it's really
counterproductive almost to cache it so
a lot of the focus in frangipani is sort
of time is pass it by a little bit it's
still useful in some situations but it's
not what people are really thinking
about in designing new systems for all
right that is it